the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire video
alright my friends i have another update
from george rr martin regarding the
ending of his books
i think some of you will be very
interested in what he had to say
i know i always am even if it's not
necessarily good news
although i think this is now as you all
know a song of ice and fire and even
game of thrones still has millions of
fans around the globe
if you follow any of the facebook groups
then you would know these books
and this show still gains new fans every
single day
i know when i first discovered the show
and watched its first episode i
immediately started wondering how this
series would end
i'm sure a lot of you are the same way i
became so obsessed with this show
i started making hundreds and hundreds
of videos where i would basically guess
what i thought would happen
during the final episodes it was a lot
of fun
and like most fans who made their own
theories i got some things wrong
but i also got some things right when
season 8 finally released we found out
how the show
ended however the final season at game
of thrones was dan and dave's version of
the events
now ever since game of thrones aired its
final episode millions of fans have been
wondering if the books will end the same
way
well the answer is yes and no based on
what george rr martin has said
this is something that dan and dave and
even george has discussed in interviews
over the years
nearly eight years ago when dana dave
sat down to do an interview with vanity
fair
they said they went out to santa fe new
mexico where george rr martin lives
and discussed his ending for the books
they were hoping george would give him
his ending
that way they could start laying the
groundwork for it in the earlier seasons
they wanted to know how everything ended
so they could set things up
they said they sat down wood george and
literally went through
each and every character the only issue
was george was only able to give them
some broad strokes
because even he didn't know all the
details yet now
although many of us like to speculate we
still don't know what those broad
strokes were
we don't know how much information
george gave them some fans think
all of the main characters will have the
same ending while others think they will
be vastly different
we did however end up getting a
confirmation about one of these
characters and that was brandon stark
after the show ended this was revealed
by the actor himself
isaac hempstead wright according to him
dan and dave
said a few things involving bran came
directly from george rr martin
and that was the hodor revelation and
that he would be king
okay so we now know bran will be the
king of something
but what about everyone else will
daenerys burn down king's landing
will jon snow ride off into the sunset
beyond the wall
will jaime and cersei die beneath the
red key will arya sail west of westeros
what about all of the characters who
were not in the final season
will stannis baratheon actually die by
brian's sword
will ramsay get devoured by his own dogs
will arya stark kill the night king
will we even see a night king in the
books obviously there are a lot of
reasons why game of thrones and a song
of ice and fire will not have the same
ending
i mean sure there will be some
similarities but at the end of the day
the stories are already vastly different
as you all know game of thrones has
killed characters that are still alive
in the books
not only that but the books also have
hundreds of more characters that game of
thrones never introduced
that reason alone is why the endings
will not be the same
it would be very hard for them to end
the same when you consider game of
thrones ended after only eight seasons
when george has said there is more than
enough material for 13 or 14 seasons
why is it ending uh i don't know ask
dave and dan when they come through
um we could have gone to 11 12 13
seasons but
they i guess they wanted a life now let
me show you what george said during an
interview
only a few days ago i think this is very
interesting
a song of ice and fire author george rr
martin was back in chicago earlier this
week
getting an honorary doctorate from his
alma mater northwestern university
while he was visiting he gave an
interview to a local station
where he discussed his writing his fame
and much more
now when they brought up game of thrones
george had this to say
it won more emmys than any other show in
television history
i'm very happy to be associated with it
it also made me famous
which i have very mixed feelings about i
think it was bill murray who said
if you dream of fame and fortune try
just fortune first
there is something to say for that fame
is definitely a double-edged sword
i've been writing stories about westeros
and the characters who live there
the seven kingdoms since 1991. it's such
a huge aspect of my life
it's transformed my life for good or for
ill
it is where i am and i do love westeros
i love writing stories about it so
there's obviously a lot more stories to
write
alright now this is where it gets good
he also said
he thinks that house of the dragon will
most likely be out next spring
and the next long-awaited book in the
series the winds of winter
fans have been waiting over a decade for
that one and martin is as frustrated as
they are
looking back i wish i'd stayed ahead of
the books he said
when they began game of thrones i had
four books already released
and the fifth one came out just as the
series was starting
i had a five book head start and these
are massive books
i never thought they would catch up with
me but they did they caught up with me
and blew right by me that made it a
little strange because now the show was
ahead of me and the show was moving in
somewhat different directions
i'm still working on the book but you'll
see my ending when that comes out
i want you to focus on what he said
right here at the end
he said the show was moving in somewhat
different directions
i'm still working on the book but you
will see my ending when that comes out
now maybe this is wishful thinking but i
think that last sentence says a lot
it doesn't just sound like his ending
will be somewhat different i think it
sounds like his ending will be very
different
based on a lot of the reasons i have
already stated earlier in this video
again maybe this is only me but it
sounds like he said
hbo gave you their ending but wait until
you see
my ending i think if they were the same
endings he wouldn't have said my ending
because that obviously separates his
from the shows but that's exactly what
he wants to do
he wants his fans to know they will not
be the same
stannis baratheon will not lose so
easily to ramsay
sir barest and selmy will not die in
some back alley
arya stark will not leap out of the sky
to kill the night king
euron greyjoy will not look and feel
like something straight out of a
spencer's gift shop
jon snow will not sit on the sidelines
during the biggest battle of his life
dany's dragons will not die the same way
they did in the show
the faceless men will not vanish from
the story
helen reed will arrive before the end
for a very good reason
lady stoneheart still has justice to
serve now i could sit here and name
things for the next hour but i will not
do that
if you have only seen the show you might
not agree with me
you might think dan and dave nailed
their landing however
if you have read the books you know
there is no way they could have the same
endings
now with all of that being said none of
this means anything if george doesn't
release the final books
as of right now game of thrones is the
only ending we have
and it will remain that way unless
george does something about it
i think i can speak for a lot of the
fans when i say george
we need you to do something about it
[Music]
you